yeah one sec
court just showed me i'm really lazy
[Music]
the kardashians are feeling more festive
than ever i'm obsessed with all of the
you know holidays and decorating and the
apple doesn't fall far from the
christmas tree as chris jenner's kids
have gone all out for the holidays i
finally have a really good idea for
christmas it may not snow in calabasas
but it's still a white christmas over at
kim kardashian's home and how about this
in the festive tour kim shared a tick
tock there's a stocking for kanye west
amid kim filing this month to become
legally single meanwhile sister
courtney's elf on the shelf game is on a
whole other level yeah one sec court
just showed me i'm really lazy kim
shared her instagram story the moment
she realized courtney goes all out for
christmas yeah one sec gorgeous showed
me i'm really lazy
this is what she showed me this year
that i am really
lazy
and i need to get it together in the
final days because i can't do this
but hey we're just hoping kim's elf made
a full recovery after this incident two
weeks ago
what's happening
it's sick why is it sick because it fell
down what do you think
girls you really
you can't be touching her courtney and
penelope's tic-tac account also
highlighted the impressive display
featuring a quick cameo from penelope's
cousin northwest o
n
g
r else
are like
crazy
and this is just the latest move in the
siblings rivalry on social media which
is all in good fun of course you know
social media is such a great tool both
kim and courtney have their own
mother-daughter accounts on tick-tock
first came courtney and penelope
followed by kim and north
west and penelope's standout moments
include this dance collab with travis
barker
helicopter
as for kim and northwest they're
definitely into singing and dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
as well as some at-home antics
back at courtney's house these
decorations had kim getting a little
sentimental oh my gosh
the forest in here
is so beautiful
with these roses
you guys these used to be at my mom and
dad's house these
santa claus and mrs claws and reindeer
since we were born
wow court
you really know how to do it up and the
mogul wasn't the only one feeling
nostalgic kris jenner shared these
throwback photos to instagram gifting
fans with a peek at holidays of days
past for the kardashians and jenners
chris paid tribute to all of her kiddos
in the caption writing christmas
memories happy holidays to each and
every one of you
[Music]